[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Thanks everyone for
joining us this afternoon
for "Building on What's Good:
A New Way to Fight Poverty."
This afternoon we
welcome Jose Quinonez
as a speaker for
Talks at Google.
I'm proud to say Jose is
a personal friend of mine
and has recently won what's
called the MacArthur Award.
Welcome Jose.
JOSE QUINONEZ: Great, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks for making time to come
and be a part of the talks.
I mean, it really is
a pleasure to be here.
Very excited to
get the invitation
to kind of share with
you some of our learnings
and in our work in poverty.
Before I start getting
into our actual work,
I did want to share
some of my story
and even kind of addressing
some of the political climate
of the day because it
actually it all impacts
a lot of the work that we do.
You know, I'm an immigrant.
I came to this country when I
was nine years old back in 1980
along with my five siblings.
The oldest at that time was 15
and the youngest kid was seven.
I'm the second to the youngest.
And I do remember crossing
the US-Mexico border
in the dark of night.
And it was actually
July 4th of 1980
when we actually
crossed at night.
We were shepherded through
the border into Tijuana.
And I remember actually feeling
very, very afraid as a kid,
not knowing what the
future had in store for us.
I mean I had no idea while we
we were making that happen.
But that happened.
That happened to me in my
life and in my family's life.
And eventually, after
crossing, we actually
made our way all
the way to San Jose
that's when we had
extended family
that we were able to live with.
And for the first couple of
years of living with them--
and I remember being
told repeatedly
to not talk about our
situation with anybody.
I think I started
in fourth grade
and they even told us to
not tell our teachers.
Don't tell anybody what is
happening with our family.
And so we learned
to kind of be quiet,
to kind if live in the
shadows and not make--
not be visible in
society at all.
But luckily in 1986 President
Reagan, at that time,
actually signed a bill that
actually gave immigrants like
my family-- myself
and my family--
amnesty.
The bill in 1986
said that anybody
that came to this
country before 1982
were granted amnesty basically.
So we had to apply and then
we were given temporary status
for a couple of years.
And after that temporary
status, we got a green card.
And after the green card we were
eligible to become citizens.
And so in '86 I remember
feeling the shadow
kind of lifting from our lives.
And for us-- really
kind of un-shackling us
so that we can actually
live the full--
our full lives to the fullest.
Right?
And so that was really
important because
without that I don't
think I would have been
able to do anything in
my professional life,
and I don't think I would
have been able to stand here
before you and talking
to you about my story
and what we've done with
the Mission Asset Fund.
I think this is a type
of story that, I'm sure,
many of you as immigrants can
probably tell that yourselves.
And I'm sure many of us have
heard stories like that where
a nine-year-old boy or
five-year-old kid can come
to this country and work hard
and have availed themselves
a lot of opportunities that we
have in our country and make
something of themselves to the
point that, professionally,
they can get to the point
of actually getting awarded
the MacArthur Fellowship--
which is one of
the highest honors
in our professional life.
And that is pretty
typical, right?
And I don't really think
that's a very unique story,
but it is my story.
And it's a story that I think
now, more important than ever,
that is to be said.
Now is more important than ever
for us to actually share those
stories because in my mind it
is those stories that actually--
that really do signify why--
what really does
make America great.
And it is about allowing
people to really truly develop
their full human and
economic potential
and then give back
into society likewise.
So I was very fortunate for
having been able to do that.
But again, I want
to sort of share
the story-- start
with that story
because in nowadays-- as you
know-- in the past two weeks,
under the new current
administration, all that
will hold true and dear in
what we believe America to be
is actually being under attack.
And I'm concerned,
not just for myself,
but for my family and the
communities that we work with.
And so this is the time
to actually, I think,
that we need to, again, speak
out more and more than ever.
So having said that, I do
want to sort of tell you
more or less about what it is
that we do at the Mission Asset
Fund and why it was that we were
awarded a MacArthur Fellowship.
The MacArthur Fellowship,
just to clarify,
is not something
that you apply for.
it's something that actually--
they just called and said
you get this thing.
You don't apply.
You don't-- you can't even
refer somebody else to apply.
It's sort of like they
sort of select you
for the creativity that--
and also the trajectory
of your work.
So it was a pretty big honor.
But I want to sort of give
you a sense of why that is
and why that happened
by giving you
more insights into our work.
And really I also want--
if you take away anything
from this conversation
I want you
to sort of to think
about this is that really
the underpinning of our work
is to work with low income
individuals to try to develop
their full financial potential
and really addressing
the issues of poverty.
And so what we've learned
in that work is this,
is that poverty is hard.
It's hard to solve.
It's really difficult actually.
It's actually very complicated.
It's a very complicated issue.
And I know that for a fact
that in the way that we've
been addressing the issue in the
past, we're not really doing--
we're not really
advancing the issue much.
And so what we've learned
is that we need to innovate.
We need to create new
programs, new ideas,
test them out and really try
to find out what exactly is--
or what exactly works
in people's lives.
And I think our work at the
Mission Asset Fund with lending
circles, primarily,
has become that example
in our national dialogue
on how to combat poverty.
So I want to definitely
talk to you more about that.
But before that, I wanted
to show you a video
because we actually have a
deep relationship with Google.
Back in 2004 for
there was Bay Area--
2014.
Sorry, I skipped
the decade there.
2014, Google had a
make the better--
Bay Area better?
SPEAKER: Build a
better Bay Area.
JOSE QUINONEZ: Build
a better Bay Area.
And I think that
was the thing that
was like over 2000 people--
SPEAKER: Oh, go ahead.
JOSE QUINONEZ: That was 2000,
I think, people applied--
organizations-- to get good
support for their work.
And we were fortunate to
actually be one of the top 10
organizations.
And because of that, Google
actually produced this video.
And so I want to stop
there and kind of make
you watch it for just a minute.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSE QUINONEZ: My
name is Jose Quinonez.
I'm the CEO of the
Mission Asset Fund.
In the Bay Area
there are thousands
of families-- hardworking
families-- that
are in the financial
shadows, people that
are invisible to the credit
system, people that are stuck
with high costs-- predatory
products-- and people who
are really strapped and have
a hard time making ends meet.
Our goal is to engage
thousands of families
and help them build their
financial capability by having
access to checking
accounts, by being
able to improve their credit
scores, create lending circles,
and being able to even pay
down their high cost debt.
And those are the
people that we actually
need to help empower with
access to the right tools
so that we can help them fulfill
their full economic potential.
Great.
Thank you so much.
So that was, again a video
that was produced by--
in that competition.
And then we had our--
when that came out and we
did a whole campaign to get
people to actually vote for us.
So it was a lot of
fun-- a lot of work--
but it was definitely a
lot of fun to engage in.
And we still use that
video to sort of, one,
introduce the nature of our
work, why we do our work,
and again just to show some
fabulous shots of folks
living in the mission.
So we started our
work back in 2007
in the Mission District working
with, and again, low income
immigrants that are trying
to build and develop
their financial capability.
For us the question was--
while we knew-- soon enough
we found out that our target
market, our target clients,
actually, by and large,
were actually-- where they
were considered unbanked--
meaning that they didn't have
a checking account or savings
account.
I think like over 50% of
adults, immigrant adults,
in the neighborhood just
didn't have a checking account.
And then we also learned
soon enough that about 44%
of mission households--
this is, again,
back in 2005 when
the study was made--
that 44% of mission households
did not have a credit score
or credit history.
And so when we we're doing
our work I said, well,
how do you actually
help people develop
their financial capability
when, in fact, they didn't have
access to the most basic
tools to actually build
their financial lives--
no checking account, no
savings account, and even
no credit score--
credit history.
So we-- so that was the barriers
that we're trying to address.
But soon enough,
too, we also realized
that that problem was
not just of people
living in the Mission District.
Those problems of being
in the financial shadows
really resonants with people all
over the country to the point
where recently there was a
study by the Federal Reserve--
and its called "The Report on
the Economic Well-being of US
Households"-- in 2015 that
they found that a lot of people
inclu--
this is 22% of employed adults.
They found that 22% of employed
adults have multiple jobs
and they actually have
multiple informal jobs.
So these are people that
are working in the gig
economy, the Uber drivers.
These are people that are
working the flea markets.
babysitting very informally
to try to make ends meet.
So imagine, one out of
every five working adults
have to contend with managing
their finances by working
in formal settings
where their incomes
can go up and down depending on
the day, depending on the week,
depending on the
month, unlike us.
Right?
We know exactly how
much we're going
to be getting paid on
a month-to-month basis,
on a year-to-year basis.
We have this, sort of,
stability of income.
But that's something that is
not the case for a lot of people
in our world.
And so that actually
presents a challenge
because the financial
instability that
comes with not being
able to predict
how you'll be making that day,
or that week, or that month--
people find the challenges of
actually managing their budgets
to the point where that same
report found that about a third
of the people that
said that they work
in this type of informal
employment-- a third of them
actually say that they
struggle to actually pay
their bills because they
don't just experience what
is called income viability.
But they also experience
a lot of volatility
in their expenses.
And so it's actually gets
harder to manage their finances
when they don't know exactly
how much they're going to get
or even how much they're
going to be paying out.
So it's harder, right?
It's harder to manage
your life like that.
And we also found,
even again, doing
more research about the
nature of poverty in our world
is that are a lot of
individuals actually
find themselves stuck where
they're at, where they actually
do not see themselves
living out what we call
the American dream anymore.
The American dream,
defining that as,
your kid will do
better than you,
or your offspring will do better
than the prior generation.
Where, in fact, back
in the 1940s the people
that were born in the 40s.
they earned more money
than their parents.
90 percent of people that
were born in the 40s--
does that make sense--
90% of people that
were born in the 1940s
made more money
than their parents.
People that were born in
1980s, about 50% of them
can actually say that.
So just in that measure
alone we actually
can see how a lot of
people are just not
even being able to realize this
idea of the American Dream.
And so they really are
stuck in where they're at.
And again, in this idea of not
being able to earn enough money
or even improve
economically in that sense,
it really bears out when you
think about the discrepancies
of how we as an
economy have improved
the level of productivity.
And again, this is very highly
cited number where since 19--
I think in the past
three decades, I think--
starting in the
middle of 1970s--
that the level of productivity
has increased significantly
from year to year to the point
that it increased by 73%.
But at the same time
period, the level
of hourly pay for workers
that actually doing the work,
their pay only increased by 11%.
So there's this growing gap
of how we're, as an economy,
increasing our productivity.
But the people that are actually
working on an hourly basis,
they're not benefiting from
that level of productivity.
So people are feeling strained.
People are feeling, again,
like they can't make ends meet
and they know that
they're not living out
to their ideals of improving
their livelihoods based
on this idea of
the American Dream.
So people are struggling.
And again, just another
statistic just to kind of bare
that a little bit more is
that one in five Americans
have no credit or
checking accounts.
So this is not just
an issue, again,
folks in our community
in the Mission District,
but this is actually
happening across the country.
And so without access to those
basic products or services,
it just makes it
virtually impossible
for them to manage, or live
out, their financial potential.
And then that actually means
that people are paying more
for financial products, because
imagine if you don't have
a checking account and
you do get payed by check,
you have to get that cashed
on a check cashing place.
And they may charge you
3% or 4% on the dollar.
And so there was another study
that actually found that just
by looking at low
income families--
these are people that are
making $24,000 or less, OK--
across the country,
that when you
look at how they
spend that money,
they found that they were
actually paying about 10%
of that on fees for
financial products--
like, again, cashing their
checks and so forth--
and interest, So they're
spending 10% of their money
to manage money.
And it actually equals
about how much money
they're spending on groceries.
I mean-- so just imagine that.
I mean, if you're only making
$24,000 a year and 10% of that,
it actually kind of goes out
to pay the lender or the check
casher store and
things like that
just because you don't
have access to the products
that you and I take for granted.
And of course, because of
that, budgets get strained.
And they cannot save.
They can't invest.
It kind of gets even
more difficult to pay
for the day-to-day expenses.
And rent alone, in large
extent, is actually
taking half of
people's annual income.
And there was a study that was
widely cited a couple of years
ago where they found that about
11 million Americans spend
half of their annual
income in rent alone.
I know that may not be
startling news for us
here in the Bay Area
in San Francisco,
because you could
be middle income,
you could be a Googler,
right, and still you
have to pay a significant
amount on rent.
I know that's the
case for us here.
But imagine, that's the
case for people and families
living in Kansas, or
living in Florida,
living in other places
that may not actually
have the benefit of having
a tech industry to rely on.
And those people
really are hurting
when half of their money is
actually going to pay for rent.
So this is really-- and
I wanted to take the time
to kind of let you paint
the picture about that.
The nature of folks
stuck in poverty
is actually pretty dire.
And they really are
grappling with things
that are really
beyond their control,
really beyond their lives.
But the reality is that when
we build policies and programs,
we sort of don't think
about that anymore.
We just sort of, like, look
at people that are poor
and sort of, kind of,
blame them for poverty.
We sort of like say, hey, no,
something's wrong with you
because you're stuck
in poverty, or you're
doing something wrong, or
you it's really your fault.
You didn't study hard enough.
You didn't go to
the right school,
or something is wrong
with you and that's why--
and we're going to leave
poverty at that level.
And this is something
that most people
know-- folks call
the deficit model,
where we actually use a deficit
perspective to build policies
and services just so it
kind of addresses that.
But the fact is-- it's kind
of like blaming the victim,
blaming them for their issues
and not really recognizing
the sort of like the broader
economic forces at play
that people are contending with.
And so this is something that we
wanted to sort of address head
on and to basically say,
is there a different way
of looking at this issue
rather than looking at it from
a deficit based-- again, that
holds people as deficient,
as ignorant, as
broken in some way--
and then looking at
people in a different way.
So that way we can figure out
how we can best align ourselves
and best leverage what they
have and we work with people so
that we can actually
help them move
through their economic journey.
And that's exactly what we
did at the Mission Asset Fund
where we came up with
a new frame, what
we call more like a
strength based approach,
where we basically start with
the idea of respecting people.
Imagine that.
Isn't that a crazy idea?
Respecting people, sort of
acknowledging their dignity.
Isn't that crazy?
It's like starting a
conversation with somebody
and saying, I
recognize your humanity
because you're another person--
that we start a
conversation based on that.
But that's something
that we felt
we needed to
actually say verbally
so that we can make
that more of our thing
because it is
definitely not happening
within our current
political environment now.
And also, by meeting people
where they're at, now where
we think they should be, or
where we want them to be.
But reality is like
kind of appreciating
their barriers, their
pitfalls, the things
that they're contending with.
But really it's about meeting
people where they're at.
And it's also about
leveraging what they have.
It's about acknowledging that
we all have something of worth.
We all have something good
to give and offer the people
and offer the world, and so
so by finding the thing that
is good in people's lives is
then figuring out how can we
leverage that so
that that way we
can continue the
conversation with them
and really truly help them
move and improve their lives.
So that is sort of the
frame that we sort of
use to talk about the MAF
approach, if you will,
and about how we think about
how we engage our clients.
And so how we took
this idea and made
it immediately
applicable to our work
is by basically noting
that one of the things that
is very common within
the immigrant community
is this idea that people
actually do come together
to help each other.
Imagine that?
This is not just
an immigrant thing.
It truly is, like, is
a human thing, right?
It's like, this what we've all
been doing for eons, right?
But people actually still do it.
And so in a sense--
from a financial sense,
it's something that we
found that immigrants
have this tradition of coming
together and to lending
and save money together.
In Mexico this is
an activity that is
called the [SPEAKING SPANISH].
All throughout the
Caribbean they call them
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
I mean they have this tradition
that happens all over the world
and comes in a lot
of different names.
Now, but this is a
very informal practice.
How many of you guys have
heard about this lending--
well, I know you guys have.
Well so this activity of
people lending each other is,
again, is very common.
But it is informal, right?
So it's informal to the point
where only the people in that
circle are the ones that,
sort of, know who they are,
know who-- because it's
really based on this--
the social trust that they
have with each other because it
mostly is each other's
neighbors, coworkers,
relatives, that they
sort of come together
to help each other out.
But so, again, the activity
has been-- is widely known,
has been written on a lot.
But because it's informal,
the formal financial systems--
the credit bureaus, the banks--
they had no idea about this.
We knew, right?
But the formal
system did not know.
So what we did
was we figured out
a way to actually make this
into a formal practice.
And this is the genesis of
what we call lending circles.
Well we found that
people in the circle--
let's say you can have
a group of 10 people,
and each person puts in $100.
So that group comes
up with $1,000, right?
And then everybody takes
$1,000 in on a monthly basis.
And they do that in
rotation so everybody
has a chance of getting $1,000.
So what we've
basically saw that is
like this was people
were making loans
and they were paying the
loans back every time
they put in $100.
So we formalized the
activity by having
people sign a promissory
note basically saying,
I, Jose, promise to pay
$100 on a monthly basis
for that $1,000 loan.
And then through that formal--
that promissory note
it gave us then,
MAF, the ability to then
serve at that loan for them
while we collect the money and
we do the loan distributions.
And then we also report that
activity to the credit bureaus.
And so right now we actually
report to the three main credit
bureaus, Experian,
Equifax, and TransUnion.
So that activity of
reporting to credit bureaus,
it actually is what helps
people start their credit score
or improve their credit
score just by virtue
of us reporting to them.
So we basically took this
activity that was informal--
but it was good, right?
Because it's people,
again, coming together
to lend each other money,
to save money together
based on trust, based on each
other's relationship which
we thought was a good thing.
And people are still doing
it in their communities.
So we took that practice
and formalized it in a way
that we can give this, sort of,
this financial benefit of being
able to start to improve
their credit scores.
And so we're going to give you
an example of the type of folks
that we work with because,
again, this activity
alone is helping people
like Michael here.
Michael, he actually
is from Ethiopia.
And he was actually
a doctor in Ethiopia,
but he came to this country
wanting to practice medicine.
But he couldn't
because he didn't have
the right credentials here.
And like every other
immigrant, they
come here it's like trying to
what the credit system is here
it's always baffling.
Right?
It's like-- because people
know that they need credit
to get credit.
But if you don't have credit
you can't get credit, right?
So people get stuck in
this, sort of a catch-22.
How many of you guys have
been stuck in a catch-22?
I know, right?
It's real.
It happens to people.
And so then the
question is like, well,
how do you break in?
How do you break
into the system?
You need to have credit
in order to get credit.
And so it's not only just
the issue for immigrants
of any type, right?
But also this is a critical
issue for young adults as well.
So Michael was it was
an example of that,
that he struggled to break
into the credit system.
But he actually joined
a lending circle.
And then so he basically
went from zero, not having--
being credit invisible, to
getting a credit score of 672
by participating in
the lending circle.
And with that credit score,
with that credit history,
he was able to,
sort of, leverage
that to continue
on in his studies
and to continue on with his
life here in the United States.
And Michael is an example of--
there's about 26-- this
is a report from the CFPV
who found that there's about 26
million adults who are credit
invisible just like Michael,
that again, they are maybe
immigrants, or
maybe young adults,
but people that are completely
invisible to the credit system.
But there's also other
people, like Alicia, who
is an entrepreneur by nature.
She actually makes tamales.
But she said she wanted
to start her business,
build her business,
but she knew that she
needed to have a good credit
score in order to leverage
loans to make that happen.
But when she came
to us she actually
had a pretty bad credit
score and even the level
of her business was
so small that even
the most good-hearted,
micro-lending,
nonprofit organization
would even give her a loan.
Now I'm not talking about the
Bank of Americas or the Wells
Fargos, these are the other
nonprofit organizations
that were already set up
to help people like her.
So they wouldn't even
lend to her because
of her financial situation.
I mean, just to kind of give
you an indication of where
she was at at the
time, she would
buy supplies to make her
tamales on a weekly basis.
And she was only--
I think she was only making
about 100 tamales per week
when she started with us.
But she got her
first loan with MAF
and then she started
building her credit.
We have helped her manage
her budgets and to the point
where in the past year she
actually grew her business
where she's now has
even seven employees
and making over $3,000
tamales on a weekly basis.
And she actually has dreams
of increasing that number
in the years to come.
But it's people
like her who had--
could have had a
bad credit score
for a lot of different reasons,
But through this program
we were able to kind
of get her to a point
where she was able to get
loans from those micro-lending
organizations and
leverage those resources
so that she can live out
her entrepreneurial dreams.
And there's other people
like Leticia as well.
Leticia is also an immigrant
who came to this country
as a young--
actually she was 26 at the time.
She was married.
She lived-- a legal,
permanent resident.
She had two children.
She had a house.
She had a business
but then life happens.
It happens to any
one of us, right?
Where, in her case, her
marriage ended up in divorce.
And her kids kind of
grew up and moved out
and then she had a couple
of foster kids to deal with.
But she actually lost
some of those investments
because of just life
happened to her.
And so she was in--
and it also was
compounded by that downturn
in the economy at that time.
But she was in a
situation where--
I remember when she came
to us she said, like, well,
I'm already resigned to the idea
that I have to wait seven years
before I kind of re-make my
financial lives because--
we all hear that, you
have to wait seven years
before you can start improving
your credit score, right?
And so we say, you know what?
You actually don't have
to wait seven years.
You can actually start now to
actually improve your credit
history so that that way she can
kind of continue on and rebuild
our financial lives.
So her credit score,
when she started with us,
it was at a very low at 324.
That's because, again, she had
a lot of-- some foreclosures
and it was really bad.
But through the years.
She was able to increase
that from 324 to 626
just by practising that.
And she was able to kind
of get back and start
in a new business as well.
And so just to kind of give
you an indication of like how--
by building on what is
good in people's lives
and actually acknowledging
that and then building
a program around it,
building an infrastructure
to make that
actually work, we've
been able to sort of
help people like Michael,
like Alicia and
Leticia, and thousands
of others to actually build
and improve and realize
their financial potential.
In terms of the
impact of our work,
we've managed over $6
million in lending circles.
And I have to say that these
are all zero interest, zero fee
loans because it's,
against, this is money
that people are
lending themselves
and we essentially are just like
the servicers of those loans.
And it's over-- now
it's about 6400 loans.
The repayment rate on
all these loans, 99.3%.
So our default rate is 0.7%.
This is completely
unheard of, even
in the micro-lending
world, where
in the average industry is
more like 12% to 14% default.
So this-- to get like a
0.7% is really remarkable.
On average, you will see
people's credit scores
increased by 160 points and
then with an average final score
of 659.
And that's, again,
it's a credit square
where now they can actually
start engaging lenders
in the micro market price.
And so we've seen significant
impacts in people's lives
over the past seven years.
And so how we did
this work, of course,
was by investing in technology.
We built a whole apparatus,
the lending circles platform,
to help us manage
these very complicated
financial transactions because
when we started our work
we couldn't go to Best
Buy and just take off--
pick up some software to
manage lending circle loans.
I mean, there wasn't
such a thing created.
So we actually had to
create it ourselves.
So we build our
platform on Salesforce.
And so that itself,
kind of gave us
the ability to
expand and increase
our work beyond San Francisco.
And then we actually even have--
we started with a
mobile friendly,
but now we're actually
creating a lending circle
app itself-- a native
app, so that way
we can help our clients manage
their money in that way.
And we've also--
and again, we do
a lot of financial education.
We provide a lot of tutorials.
They deal is we partner
with a group called EverFi
and we use a lot of
their videos to provide
financial insights on how to
navigate the financial system.
What we saw is that financial
education alone by itself
is really irrelevant.
It doesn't really work.
But when you actually tie it
to a financial product where
people actually learn something
from the activity itself,
we actually saw that people
were able to improve their score
by an additional 27 points
than if people were just
doing the financial
product by itself.
So that that number
itself kind of
made me a believer that
financial education,
when his properly presented
to people in a way that
is easy to use and
manageable, it actually
had a significant
impact on their lives.
And we're also
expanding our work
by way of franchising
the model with
other nonprofit organizations.
We're actually engaging
other organizations,
other nonprofits,
so that way they
can deliver lending circles
to their own communities
and then we manage all
of the technology--
all of the operations--
on the back end.
So that way we can
expand by having just one
office in San Francisco
but the technology
we're definitely expanding that.
So right now we have
about 52 providers
in 17 different states plus
the District of Columbia.
And so on the final
slide I want to,
again, reiterate the key
takeaways from our work.
And this is something
that I definitely
wanted to come back to it, which
is in addressing poverty alone,
it is a difficult
issue, but we have
to think about it
in a different way
so that where we can actually
provide significant impact
in people's lives.
In the way that we've been
thinking about it in the past,
I feel that that is not
working and people are actually
getting stuck there even more.
And so we also need
to find solutions
that are grounded in people's
lives not in what do we--
on the assumptions that
we have of their lives
or whatever alternative
facts we may
have of people in
their struggles,
but in the actual
lived experiences.
And in through that our hope
is that America's beacon
will shine once
again when we truly
can remove all those
barriers and pitfalls
and actually allow people
to realize their full human
and financial potential.
And so that, if anything--
if you can remember anything
please remember those two
things, that poverty is hard.
It's not an easy thing.
It's not something
you can just wish away
but we actually do have to
engage in people's lives
and really bring about some
significant benefit to who they
are.
So I'll stop there and take
any questions or just to-- oh,
yes-- to make sure that for all
of you Googlers out in YouTube
land--
yeah, I can say that--
definitely love for you
guys to engage with us
through everyday heroes.
This really is a time to be
generous with your resources,
with your talent.
Based on what we've seen
in the past two weeks,
we're going to be in a fight
for the next four years.
And this is really where
we need all hands on deck
to actually make an impact
and support and defend
what we hold true, not just
for immigrants, but really
for America as it is.
So be generous with
your time and resources.
Engage with us.
Join us and then we'll figure
out a way to make common cause.
And I'll leave you with
my contact information.
You can always email me,
or call, or visit, or us
or tweet us and so that
way we can find a way
to converse with you.
So I'll end there,
but if there's
any questions or any comments--
AUDIENCE: So how can you
keep the default rate so low?
SPEAKER: Yes, that's
a great question.
I know-- people
always ask us that.
And I think it's
because of this, it's
that we start our work
by showing them respect.
We start the conversations
by saying, look,
we're here to help.
These are zero interest,
zero fee loans.
This is their money, right?
And then we also
require for people
to come together in a group and
see each other face-to-face so
that they know who is
in that lending circle
and they have a common
relationship there.
Now, they may not necessarily
be each others friends, or best
friends, or neighbors, they
may be total strangers.
But because they're-- we're sort
of managing it as a nonprofit
and we're giving them the
benefit of reporting it,
people follow through
with their commitment.
And so-- and we also tell
them, it's like, you know what?
If there's a default,
we take the hit.
MAF takes a hit, right?
And so there's a commitment
that we show them.
And I think that commitment
to that they show us in return
and they pay us back.
I mean, that's one
level of answering.
Another thing is, too, our
technology makes it really easy
for them to participate.
We don't require
them to send a check
or we don't say you have to
come here before 5 o'clock
on Friday or else we're going to
close the door and that's that.
So we make it easier.
So we're, in a sense,
we're leveraging technology
just like in the way that you
want to leverage technology
to make your financial
transactions easy.
We're giving them the
same power of technology
to make their their
financial lives easy
so they can actually, then,
pay us in an easy way.
AUDIENCE: So if the
lender and the borrower
don't necessarily know each
other before they come to you,
what is the primary
incentive for the people
to front the money
to participate?
JOSE QUINONEZ: Yeah, so we've
asked that question to folks
because if you get the lending
circle distribution at the end,
you're essentially putting in
$100 every month and at the end
you get the $1000.
So essentially you're
kind of saving.
So some people do it because of
that because they want to save.
They want that sort of
social commitment to save.
They want to make that social--
or out-- they want
to make that--
be forced to do that like
a compulsory savings habit,
if you will.
So some people
have that benefit.
But other people, they know that
by them putting in their money
at play, that the others
will get their money
and then be able to sort
of pay down high cost debt.
So they're helping other people.
And that's something, again,
that is actually important
because when we think
about poor people,
we don't think about them as
having the potential for them
to helping each other.
But in this case, we
actually see that where
there like some people
want the other person
to be the first
to take that $1000
loan so that they can
deal with their issues.
And so I feel good,
they feel good.
They feel good because
they're helping their neighbor
and helping other people
manage their lives.
So their incentive is not
necessarily just monetary
because they get no benefit.
We're not giving
them a dividend.
We're not giving them
an interest payment.
They're going to get
$1,000 at the end, right?
But I think it's like they
like the social component of it
just as well.
AUDIENCE: The lenders,
are they people
from the same social
circles as the borrowers?
JOSE QUINONEZ: Yes.
So imagine that 10 people
in the lending circle
are both the lenders
and the borrowers.
So imagine, if you're the
first person to get the $1,000,
you're the borrower and the
nine people are lenders.
And then if you're
the second person,
you then transform yourself
from a lender to a borrower.
And then the other eight
people are lenders--
they're lenders, right?
And so when you get that
lump sum distribution you
transform yourself
into the lender.
So they're both the lenders
and borrowers at the same time.
And so it's kind of hard to
imagine because traditionally
we think about the
external resource that
comes in-- a bank is money
and then we pay them back.
And that's the only
relationship they have.
But here, it's like we manage
to do it in the traditional way.
Like this actually--
this is how they do it.
And by us formalizing
it, we were
able to give people the
benefit of reporting it
to the credit bureaus.
AUDIENCE: Could you
speak a little bit more
about your expansion across
the country in collaboration
with other nonprofits?
I'm just curious how
you're working with them
and what their role is in the--
JOSE QUINONEZ: Yeah.
Thank you for that.
So one of the things
that in nonprofit sector
we do a lot is we talk
a lot about cooperation.
We talk about doing
things together
because it's just
our nonprofit speak.
You guys have your
own Google speak,
we have our own nonprofit speak.
But in reality, it's
actually very hard
to work with other
nonprofits in coalition.
Particularly when we talk
about products and services
because as a
nonprofit that product
is our intellectual
property, right?
And so when you actually
kind of give it away
it sort of diminishes
people's ability to actually
fundraise or support that.
So we talk a lot about
it but it actually
never happens in a great deal.
So how we found
a way to do that,
however, we found a
way to essentially kind
of franchise the product.
We franchise our
program when we engage
nonprofit organizations that
want to implement the program.
And then we have a
contract with them
to say we're going to give you
the program as a franchise,
and then we're going to give
you the TA, the training
and technical assistance
for them to implement it.
But it is still our product.
So that way we can still keep
quality control over it, right?
And so that we can
engage with them.
And then they, in
turn, pay us a fee.
They pay us a license
fee for managing that.
But then what they get in return
is that they have-- now there's
a phenomenal innovative
product where they can actually
fundraise around it.
So that they can
support their staff time
and their operation-- which is
exactly what needs to happen.
And so, in a sense, by us giving
it away as a franchise product,
we were able to
sort of replicate it
without us going to those
cities and starting nonprofit--
I mean, [INAUDIBLE]
as an office, right?
Because for us, that's actually
it's a cost prohibitive path
because there's no
resources that we
can tap to open 50 offices
across the country,
much less even 10 or two.
I mean, it's just
hard for nonprofits
because we don't have
access to venture capital
or the sort of resources
that could help us with that.
So here, we basically took
a page from our clients
actually-- which is partner.
Work with each other.
Trust each other.
Have a relationship with each
other that is that there is
mutual in effect, right?
So in that sense
it's working well.
Now, the work,
however, is about you
have to continually trained.
There's a lot of the
technology that we
have had to build to make
sure that they're actually
using that technology properly.
And we have to retrain
and retrain constantly
so that the staff can implement
the program correctly.
But that really was the only
way for us to scale on the way
that we have scaled.
I sort of say that and I
started at the beginning
by saying that
like in nonprofits
we talk a lot about cooperation
but it doesn't happen a lot,
it's because it's
just hard to do.
And so there's not a lot of
examples of-- in the nonprofit
field--
of others that have franchised
their programs in the way
that we have.
And I think that's just one of
the sad realities of our field.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Good questions.
I have a question now that
I don't know the answer to.
Does the Mission Asset Fund
except direct donations?
JOSE QUINONEZ: No
we did not accept--
[LAUGHS] yes, we do
accept direct donations.
So if you, again,
can give generously--
I know you have
a lot of talents.
A lot of your expertise can
also be a great benefit to us.
We have a lot of
ideas but we really
are poor in time and
resources and talent.
So if you guys want to sort
of help with that regard,
we know we can, again,
tinker and innovate
to make something happen.
So thank you so much
for the opportunity
to come to the Google
campus and share our story.
I think there's something
that is real there
and we definitely are trying
to share with the world.
And in times like this we have
to sort of tell our stories,
as an immigrant, about what
we're doing on the edges
because this is really
what makes America great.
And we want to sort
of protect that.
And we will need to defend that.
And not allow somebody
else to tell us otherwise
because I do not believe
that the current president is
going to write the last
chapter in America.
He does not have that
authority no that right.
We will.
But we have to continue working
together to make that happen.
So again, thank you
so much for your time.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]